boa noite boa noite bem tem uma pergunta
como é que a gente pode transformar algo
difícil algo que pode ser considerado
uma tragédia em algo positivo em algo
que dê sentido para a vida de uma pessoa
e de outras que estão em volta
então aqui agora vou contar essa
história que começou há muitos anos
atrás e que começou com o grande desafio
um grave acidente né na vida de um homem
que tinha muita vontade de viver
só que esse grave acidente fez com que
quase tudo que ele fazia fosse
paralisada
ele parou de andar para de falar é é a
quantidade de amigos que ficaram perto
foram bem poucos e a vida parecia estar
e meio parada pararam mesmo né por um
bom tempo ficou meio parado ele ficou
incólume e o fato de ele ter ficado em
coma e teve que fazer com que ele fosse
para um outro lugar distante da onde ele
morava
então ele passou um bom tempo longe da
namorada dele e todo mundo que estava
envolta a primeira família né ela hélice
e sensibilizaram para poder dar algum
suporte e no caso o primeiro suporte que
eles tinham que dar a físico mesmo né
um outro lugar alguém tinha que ficar
sempre indo lá visitando é uma pessoa um
revezamento de pessoas para poder estar
lá
e visitando é na medida que podia né
aquela pessoa que estava precisando
efe rené estava precisando de saúde de
coragem de muitas coisas
só que o processo do coma né
às vezes ele demora muito e demorou
bastante depois que ele saiu do coma é
também muitas operações acidente
realmente foi uma coisa muito forte e
depois que ele passou ele necessitava de
um suporte que não era só físico que nem
num primeiro momento ele precisa num
outro suporte que era algo que pudesse
vir à tona é aquele sentimento a todos
que mantivesse ele vivo e aí você pode
não tem fim
ele não tem o paulo ele voltou para o
lugar onde ele vivia
só que leu alguma coisa estava se
movimentando né a força que ele sim era
tão grande que acaba que o coração
continuava pulsando e tava pedindo
alguma coisa que as pessoas também volta
ainda não sabia direito o que era irmão
da família bem próximo
ele já tem dia terapeuticamente várias
pessoas né
seus maiores desafios só que de repente
do nada começou a surgir dentro de uma
tapera que era bem simples vizinha que
tinha é o tatinho de saber que era
pequena pequena um pouquinho maior do
que esse círculo que a gente tem aqui
esse círculo vermelho
ano e meio dentro daquela tapera
ele começou a atender algumas pessoas
que chegavam que até então não tinham
chegaram eram cadeirantes
eram pessoas que tinham defeitos físicos
defeitos não gosto dessa palavra mas
falei é tinham dificuldade né
vamos falar assim e cada dia que passava
chegava mais gente chegava mais gente
o irmão que já têm dia ele falou gente
está precisando de ajuda
é bom que a gente consiga fazer algumas
alianças que os amigos que estão
sensibilizadas me ajudem porque as
pessoas passavam ali e tinham que tem um
bom conforto tinham que dar um sentido
para a própria vida né
então ele era bom é na conjuntura
a companheira dele era boa
é na arte era bem fera na na quarta ela
conseguia fazer com que as pessoas que
chegassem ali naquele ambiente tivessem
vontade de de pintar mais adiante chegou
uma outra pessoa que ajudava é aquele
trabalho colocando cada fiozinho no tear
e e aquelas pessoas têm a oportunidade
de ter seu próprio é sentido né data da
vinda delas aconteceu devagarinho é que
esse homem que estava em tratamento aí
sim ele voltou da cidade distante e
começou a receber aquele alimento que
passava por oficina né então era tinha a
oficina de tecelagem nem tinha o próprio
atendimento terapêutico que o irmão
fazia tinha a oficina de artes com o
passar do tempo ea chegada de mais
pessoas naquele espaço era bem pequeno
min as pessoas que estavam ali no dia a
dia resolveram que tinha que fazer algo
além daquilo além daquele espaço é
necessário é conseguir se relacionar ver
de que forma
é aquilo tudo podia crescer então é a
acionar é o poder público para ver se
conseguiam um terreno mas ele não tinha
dinheiro na verdade eles foram lá na
cara de pau chegaram e pediram será que
dá pra ter um terreno trabalho que a
gente está realizando ali é também um
espaço pequeno a gente precisa que isso
expandir cada vez chegam mais pessoas e
tudo mais e pró por obra do destino o
espaço veio o terreno foi cedido
tá aí se defrontaram uma situação lindo
né tá aqui o terreno e cadê o dinheiro
então não tinha dinheiro pra modificar
nada daquilo mas sim uma coisa era muito
importante todo mundo que se chegava pra
pra fazer parte daquele trabalho não
chegava o dom da pessoa era cozinhar não
ficava lá cozinhava fazia comida para
aquelas pessoas que estavam ali que
passava boa parte do dia a dia
o outro era bom
arrumando o quintal estava ali cuidando
para não ter nenhum bicho que pudesse
entrar no espaço
o outro era bom era bom em contatos né
eram pessoas que já conheciam ali a
cidadezinha já conheciam a prefeitura já
conheciam vários segmentos não é que
podiam dar suporte para aquela para
aquele trabalho pra dar continuidade
então e tinha outras pessoas né assim
acaba de uma notícia quando ela é boa né
quando algo bom tá acontecendo vai sendo
divulgada
as pessoas vão espalhando né e assim foi
as pessoas quando espalhando a notícia
gente lá você não sabe que você faz com
o seu filho tem essa dificuldade
op tem o pessoal ali que atende que pega
e trabalha com arte itália todo santo
dia talvez seja bom você ir lá e assim
foi
cada vez mais é cada vez o trabalho
sendo conhecido no local
passou um tempo lá do outro lado do
mundo
num continente no continente europeu é
uma pessoa de um país do do continente
europeu chegou através de um amigo e
sobre daquele trabalho estava existindo
resolveu visitar chegou lá para visitar
olhou aquele espaço que ainda era
pequenininho né pouquinho maior do que
esse tapete e falou olha eu tô vendo o
trabalho que vocês estão realizando e
realmente eu estou a fim de ajudar esse
senhor
ele queria ajudar porque lá no país que
ele vivia ele tinha sido responsável por
começar junto com outras pessoas
um trabalho semelhante que hoje é um
trabalho assim em referência é um
trabalho muito grande eles têm 65
pessoas era na época que eu conversei
com ele não sei se já mudou
é então e já durava mais de 30 anos
vou dar força pra isso vocês têm tem
como conseguir o terreno a pessoa que
estava responsável falou não tem a gente
já vem a gente não tem o dinheiro para
construir e assim foi
essa pessoa foi de lá de longe pegou
ajudou aquele trabalho existir só que
não foi só essa pessoa é todo mundo
ali no dia a dia era como se fosse o
próprio tijolinho da obra
era como se a força de todas aquelas
pessoas que chegavam e as pessoas que
estavam ali trabalhando se
disponibilizando para realizar aquele
serviço fosse o o que sustentava de fato
aquele trabalho e aí surgiu né
o que a gente batizou e que não deve ser
à toa que a gente vai resolver esse nome
né nato tem essa palavra é a associação
beneficente arcanjo gabriel gabriel já
escutaram falar por aí dontal arcanjo
gabriel a matava tapera de sapê
é melhor passar um tempinho maior
eles começaram a fazer algo que tinha
que ter uma linha condutora né
e essa linha condutora ela tem um nome
antroposofia antroposofia a gente foi
olhar no dicionário a antroposofia ela
vem do grego quer dizer sabedoria do
homem assim antroposofia tava ali
impregnada naquele trabalho era a gente
tinha como missão não é como objetivo
resgatar toda essa sabedoria que tava
ali em cada individualidade daquela e se
você for pesquisar você vai ver que a
antroposofia ela não se limita a um
aspecto só é das das ciências na então
ela está na medicina está na pedagogia
ela está na agricultura ela vai ajudando
em várias áreas do conhecimento mesmo né
assim pensando nisso foi estruturado
todo um ritmo diário onde as oficinas
elas fazem parte elas são a
possibilidade das pessoas que estão ali
trabalhar em realizar em algo
de acordo com as suas próprias
capacidades e tentando transpor os
limites que elas apresentam se
relacionando com os outros levam cada um
ali onde o mais habilidoso ajuda o que
tem dificuldade onde o próprio fato de
estar junto o próprio fato de itália
passando horas junto é comendo plantando
tecendo o próprio fato disso já causa
algo que é útil e que é capaz de
fortalecer aquele indivíduo é capaz de
dar sentido mesmo que nem eu falei no
começo da conversa é a vida daquelas
pessoas e nas outras também estão ali
então assim basicamente essas oficinas
elas têm o dia a dia né o ritmo diário
ele é composto com uma harmonização é
onde a gente chega das mãos em roda um
recebe a mão do outro o outro dá aquela
mesma mão que recebeu é aquela mesma mão
de eleger ou não mas a mão que recebe
também é capaz de dar algo para o outro
e assim a gente faz a roda respira fundo
silencia
cada um tem as suas casas cada um vem
dos seus ambientes então é preciso
também para um pouquinho frei aquele
movimento a gente respira fundo
a seguir a gente faz um verso a gente
falar algo que seja relativa à época a
época do ano que a gente está vivendo
depois dali a gente faz um lanche todo
mundo com 1
junto acabou lanche a gente pega e vai
até as oficinas realiza algo trabalha
cada uma sua é de selagem meio ambiente
trabalhos manuais artes e ofício e
sempre que é necessário essas mesmas
pessoas também participam dos
atendimentos individuais e e às vezes
pode ser até grupal onde ela recebe um
conforto através de uma terapia que o
aromaterapia é pensar lá numa terapia
escalda-pés que não sei se vocês sabem
mas é é algo que você põe maganha
quentin que você fica ali junto com
aquelas com aquela ganha tem uma erva
que vem que a calma que ajuda para que a
pessoa encontre o seu equilíbrio
então assim são diversas terapias né a
sessão algumas delas e assim aquele
processo né de estar junto é nas
oficinas ou no atendimento
é terapêutico passou aquela manhã tendo
aquele tipo de alimento ela volta e
encontra com todo o grupo se alimenta
com a comidinha mesmo o arroz e feijão
alface que é plantada lá no mesmo dar
uma comida bem simples e depois que ela
só ele do do almoço ela vai descansar um
pouco numa rede num colchão
ela não tem pinho da uma freiada para
ajudar na digestão ajudou ali aquela de
gestão daquele alimento que não é só o
físico não é só o arroz com feijão é
todo aquele momento
anteontem esforço é você pegar perceba
se pegar implantava ajudou naquela parte
você está ali bem presente naquele
momento
o que acontece é que ela continua
participar de uma oficina mas com a
liberdade de escolher o que ela vai
fazer é querer inventar outros querem
continuar acontecendo tenho tenho uma
delas lá que quer trabalhar o tempo
inteiro em outras pessoas que não querem
trabalhar não que são mais vagar e aí
nesse momento a gente respeita mesmo
isso acabou e depois do almoço não dá
uma preguiça danada então a gente vai
indo de acordo com o a possibilidade
cada um de acordo com um o que cada um
está querendo ler
tá aí depois disso que a gente faz e se
esse descanso essa oficina mais livre a
gente retorna e se encontra de novo e
faz um lanche e por último a gente fecha
o dia lembrando as coisas que
aconteceram naquele dia e que com
certeza contribuíram de alguma forma
para que aquela pessoa que estava ali
ela ela ela conseguiu agir ela conseguiu
tirar de dentro uma força ela conseguiu
produzir algo ela conseguiu tem dias que
não consegue nem a gente não tem nada de
diferente sem diz que ele está mais
preguiçoso tem dias que a gente está com
um álbum em roma do da mesma forma que a
gente funciona funcionam todos e aí a
gente faz a retrospectiva pensa nas
coisas boas e nas coisas mais difíceis
que a gente conseguiu realizar ali cada
1 retorna para sua casa para celular pra
depois no outro dia tá ali de 9 de
segunda a sexta de 8 6 até três e meia
da tarde
e esse trabalho
muitas vezes ele é colocado mostrado
para o público na então a gente segue é
um cara
andaram que respeita e que valoriza as
os acontecimentos que a questão durante
aquele ano tudo né então é tem tem
ligação com as estações do ano
nesta as coisas são realmente tudo que
eu escutei hoje aqui né eu achei que
tava tudo dentro do do encaminhamento
até mesmo quem agora está podendo falar
isso então tem a ver com os ritmos
cíclicos da natureza e por que a gente
acha importante focar isso porque
através de você saber você se situar
como é que se situa no mundo você se
situa no mundo quando você começa a
observar o que acontece na então no
verão uma chuva dá nada
o solo está encharcado no outono
tem coisas ali acontecendo há um
processo de transformação acontecendo as
as folhas das árvores caiam e vão pro
pro solo é bom pro solo e vão fertilizar
aquele solo é no inverno é frio é
necessário acender uma fogueira linha
vai poder estar junto
assim todas essas passagens né que
acontecem durante um ano
elas são responsáveis para que a pessoa
possa tá agindo de acordo com a sua
essência
então com fruta né com o passado esses
21 anos
o que acontece é que a terra na terra já
foi plantado algo aquela terra fria sabe
lembra aquela terra que falava é que era
mais ou menos o começo da história e que
em que era a possibilidade de algo novo
ser plantado uma semente plantada com
todo aquele acidente que aconteceu e
aquela semente ela se transformou numa
planta e hoje ela está aqui com seus 21
anos
dando os frutos e é esse futuro eu quero
compartilhar com todos vocês